our next guest is considered by many to
be the second best offensive tackle to
ever come out of USC and that's not a
bad thing the first draft pick ever by
the Jacksonville Jaguars he helped them
reach the FC title game has seen several
Super Bowls on TV he's considered one of
the best offensive tackles damper play
in the NFL
oh just not by the Hall of Fame at least
not yet hopefully that will be corrected
this weekend by the selection committee
please welcome Toni's bacilli
[Music]
[Applause]
and to slim down actual compliment oh
yeah because you're making fun of me
over there I'm like no no that's a good
thing Anthony Anthony munos right yeah
is now you widely he's do you consider
him the best offense and I think he's
the best offensive lineman ever
yeah I do too I mean ever play the game
so I'm happy to be second fiddle to him
but he was athletic you know usually
when you see a big tackle
he just is a big guy and Anthony Mooney
was played on the baseball team at USC
and just was more of an athletic tackle
than I think we were used to in the NFL
yeah I played baseball in junior high no
he's a great I think your point is he
was one of the first guys who was big
athletic could move around multi-sport
guys so yeah but there's a lot of guys
since then have kind of been that mold
do you have to be big now to be a good
offensive lineman oh yeah I think so I
don't think there's very many small guys
but but I'm talking about that ya know
like speed like how much more important
like great footwork quickness I know you
have to have strength but I think I mean
I still think feet are the most
important thing I mean aesthetic ability
if you could move and stay in between
you and the quarterback I mean you have
a chance I mean I think the day of the
big you know heavy fat lumbering
especially at the office a lot offensive
tackle position I don't think you can do
that I mean you got Von Miller and guys
like that coming off the edge I mean
it's hard enough you're if you're a
really good athlete to block those guys
if you're big and lumbering out to give
a chance but what did you ever have a
moment where you got beat and do you you
know can you yell out to Mark Brunell
like look out or do you say sorry there
was a you know there was very few
moments where I got beat that quick but
there's a couple that come to mind I
remember playing we were playing the
Tennessee Jevon Kearse beat me pretty
quick and I was literally watching
whole thing in slow motion and I'm
thinking this is not gonna end well for
mark I mean it's over for me already it
already so at this point it doesn't
matter but you can't yell you can't do
anything you want to you try to try to
tackle and miss that and and it did not
end well do you are you taught to hold
like um play no I mean I think I mean
you you're gonna grab I mean but you
have always a difference between art of
holding I mean if you're holding within
C but my thing is if you hold within the
framework of the body and you move your
feet you're never gonna get called for
it okay Poli jump up and let Tony show
you the difference between holding and
grabbing right so you're gonna come off
come this way like that right there
good okay right here I can grab right
here if I'm in the framework of the body
and moving here he goes this way Tony
stand over there and let Paulie try to
get around you like that like
legitimately this this is to get into
the Hall of Fame okay
[Applause]
he was actually he wanted to do that
today I don't know why I felt bad for a
second until he was really trying no no
no he wants to do that we've got a long
list of mistakes at the Super Bowl by
Paulie he said to Clay Matthews I'm
gonna block you and Clay Matthews hit
him in the chest it gave him that stab
oh yeah he tried to tackle Adrian
Peterson and Matt Forte they smacked him
in the head of it I'm impressed yeah
yeah you are
no it's not no it's no all right so
final 15 for the Hall of Fame yep now I
do want to point this out only because
people think that we known each other
forever I never I don't think I ever met
you before
until recently yeah and I just said look
I know what I saw when I saw you play
and I thought you were there was
something different there was a
athleticism you were a great player now
the window that you played is probably
what if it does keep you out of the Hall
of Fame would be the along you know the
amount of time you play but when you
played when you played it at a high
level of newer healthy there was no
other tackle that I saw that was better
than you and I'm talking about Anthony
Munoz I'm talking about the Great's of
the game so I don't I don't know you but
I know when I see a Hall of Famer and I
look at you the way I do Terrell Davis
now he won Super Bowls and won an MVP
rushed for 2,000 yards but you know
there's no real number I can attach to a
tackle to say well but he did this and I
hope you get into the Hall of Fame I
hope you get the call and they tell you
one Saturday that you're in the Hall of
Fame I appreciate it I mean it's the one
of those things you know you're not
playing anymore there's nothing I can do
about it but it's the ultimate
individual honor and my career is what
it was I got hurt much like Terrell
Davis did I think when he got in that
meant a lot yeah
I'm along before you mentioned me in
your Hall of Fame speech like hell
I usually show up a little later
probably and I think how long do I have
I mean they say it's too long I'm not
gonna be like the 45-minute where you go
on until your whole life story so if I
let's say I go 15 minutes I think when
do I get mentioned eleven and a half to
12 I like it yeah where it's emotional
emotional tears yeah now do you cry
mentioning me or your family well I
think it's a carryover from my mom and
dad to wife and kids then you the tears
are continuing the entire time and if
you just say Dan we did it like then I'm
fine with that too like it doesn't have
to be a big day Dan Patrick how about
some like damn without you I'm not sure
this day is real I'll work on that now
I'm not I'm not joking like I'd expected
like a damn good showdown well the good
news is there's a local guy named Dan as
well who asked me the same thing so I
think I can kill two birds with one
stone just say Dan and both of you will
think that okay that's part of the deal
I'm fine with that [ __ ] Tony is the lead
analyst for Thursday Night Football in
Westwood one and you're gonna be on the
sidelines for the Super Bowl
yes are you nervous no okay okay and
explain this to the audience this is I
think it's unfair to you I really do for
know I do for the 15 finalists yeah
because you're all in a room no so
actually we're all at a hotel
they fly everybody and I'm here all week
because of the radio with Westwood one
but everyone else is here Thursday you
do an event Thursday night there's a
luncheon Friday and then Saturday you're
told just to sit around all day and all
48 voters go into a room and they tell
you be in your hotel room about 3:30
because from 3:30 on 3:30 to 5:00 you
either will get a knock on the door
meaning you're in the Hall of Fame or a
phone call meaning you're not in the
last two years I forgot the phone call
the first year was the worst because I
was sitting there I and the first try
actually didn't think I was gonna make
it
it was a long shot and I'm sitting there
and my wife's there and I hear a knock
on the door and it was housekeeping
[Laughter]
and I will open the door nice and as
nice as I possibly could I said we
please get thee away from leave and then
about 30 seconds later the phone rang
and they let me know you are not good
enough to be in this group please go
home now and collect your belongings
they didn't say that but that's what it
okay put it Do Not Disturb sign yes yes
okay so you get the phone call it's over
in the hard part but the phone call is
now they tell you you literally have
five minutes to get downstairs go to the
honors because they want all 15 guys
with honors and so you you know put the
suit and tie on and go to the honors and
sit there and the best way I can explain
it is you're sitting there and you know
we're all type-a competitive guys you
you know you've always kind of risen to
the top and one of the best of what you
do and you it feels like the whole
thing's great about Dave Baker does an
amazing job but you feel like they're
basically saying you are not good enough
you've been cut I mean that's the
feeling you have because there's 15 guys
only five make it well it feels like
there's a log jam with linemen this year
so I do think a couple alignment are
getting in I don't know it Steve
Hutchinson Kevin malai Alan you Alan
Faneca and you said you're better than
all of those guys well I'm the best
tackle of the group all here it's clear
it feels like they're gonna the log jam
it's gonna bring in a couple of linemen
I hope so I mean I think that's two for
sure
guys I'm ed Reed and Tony Gonzalez I
mean is out there getting and out and
then my guess is you're handicapping and
probably can't barely be next I would
agree with that too and then there's two
open spots maybe three depending what
they do a champ and I think they should
with two offensive linemen and your last
year was five offensive linemen at the
top 15
Joe Jacobi aged out you can't be in
there any longer and now there's four of
us so we'll see what happens all great
players I mean that's the other thing
you kind of look at it and if you don't
get last year's haven't gotten in and
you want to be mad at somebody but then
you look at the guys who get in we're
gonna say Oh Louis who's the best player
you ever saw offensively defensively the
best player like what you
just went Wow you know there's a couple
and I'll say from being young because
watching these guys growing up I mean
John Elway was my favorite player of all
time growing up in Colorado and so
watching him and playing against them I
was like my goodness and then you beat
him for in the Denver which was the
greatest thing ever watching Barry
Sanders we played them in 95 seeing him
live and what he was able to do it was
remarkable and being on the same field
Reggie White
just the the the amount of power and
strength and what he was able to do was
unbelievable so I mean there you put on
the list of the great players to play
but those guys really stand out that's
something special could you beat up all
four of my guys at the same time yeah
there's not a doubt if we okay if we
said you could not leave this carpeted
area
I'm confident a couple I take out
immediately just one punch they're done
Fritzi for its ease probably the weakest
link here even though he's got big are
his arms ours was not the one I heard
talking about like neurological issues
yeah yeah definitely
he's got issues going on yes I think I
may have bowel issues of my face and
McLovin I don't know if I did remember
the bench press then oh yeah he did
bench press 200 pounds 200 pounds yeah I
could get it I've got up to 215 in my
time max yeah what's your max there's a
lot more than that my shoulders don't
even work anymore and it'd still be more
than that they screwed up your shoulder
didn't they yeah there was some mishaps
I think that's unfortunate there's no
reason that they go how's your shoulder
now oh it's complete crap the good news
is so this is I saw a doctor probably
four or five years ago about it and I'm
hoping to get it cleaned out you know or
something that's what athleanx Owen till
I can't play golf anymore
okay I'm gonna play but that's about all
the external that's as far as it goes
but I had the knee replaced yeah have
you done that no yeah I got my knees i
the hip okay
well they've mastered the hip yeah I was
like no problem the hips good I played
golf like three weeks later
yeah the knee knee takes low
how does Sunday play out I said a hard
time seeing the Patriots lose I don't
know why do you hate the Patriots know I
don't I have a lot of friends that you
know they call me going to the games and
you know doing all the games they said
gosh we hope the patient's we're so
tired of the Patriots and I think it's
easy to take that point of view to me
it's just the opposite I mean how often
it's the greatest sports dynasty in my
opinion in my lifetime
if you look at the NFL set up for parody
yeah set up for the bad teams to be
decent from draft order from salary cap
everything is going against the dynasty
and that's what I think it's greater
than anything that the 49ers did the
Cowboys of the day or the Steelers what
Belichick and Brady have done in this
era is the most remarkable thing I've
ever seen I mean they've been to Garrett
together now like 17 years of work
Brady's been healthy nine Super Bowls
there's guys on that there's think about
this there's guys in the roster who've
been played in the NFL for eight years
and they've been to the AFC Championship
every year what are you talking about
you talking about I got twice I mean
guys never get there yeah then the Super
Bowl three straight years jotoon he's
never not played a season of football
this starting left guard without playing
the Super Bowl so I think that I think
the pay it's a very close game I think
the Patriots just edged out the Rams
final question yep you can have Julian
Edelman career or Calvin Johnson's I'm
going out of me okay I thought about in
the beginning and then I thought well
Calvin Johnson and then I realized
Edelman it is probably not going to the
whole fam know but you can't tell the
story of the NFL without Julian Edelman
you came out and he had two of the most
iconic plays in Super Bowl history and
he's not done yet so I I said Edelman
even though my bank accounts not gonna
be say the only thing is I start looking
at my my finances
yeah I'm like Calvin Johnson be pretty
nice but what he's done on Idol men on
the field and to plays Brady I think
that'd be awesome
I hope you get the call or the knock on
Saturday it'll be a big portion of
because of you of course of course
thank you thank you he's Tony Boselli
Westwood one lead Thursday night analyst
and he will be on the sidelines for the
call on Westwood one on Super Bowl
Sunday for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]